You know, I've heard this for years, being in the Hollywood business, that for every 100 auditions, you'll book one job. So just keep going and keep going. And I thought, gosh, for every 100 episodes of Smartless, there's always one good one. So we've got about three in the can. Welcome to Smartless. Guys, guess what's coming up in a couple weeks?
你知道，我在好莱坞这一行待了这么多年，一直听说每试镜100次，你才能接到一份工作。所以就是不断地尝试，不断地尝试。我就想，天哪，Smartless播了100集，总算有一集是好的。所以我们现在大概录好了三集。欢迎来到Smartless。伙计们，猜猜几周后有什么大事？
Yeah, yeah, I know. We've got to mention. Oh, my God. Yeah, the Hollywood Bowl. We're going to be at the Hollywood Bowl October. Tober 17th. And not just there, like not hanging out, actually doing a show at the home.
是啊，是啊，我知道。我们得提一下。天哪。没错，好莱坞露天剧场。我们10月17日要去好莱坞露天剧场。不仅仅是去那里，不是去闲逛，而是真的要在那个地方做一场演出。
We're going to be on the stage. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And if you don't have tickets yet, you go to smartlist.com slash live, is that right? Wait, what's it? What is it? Smartlist.com slash live. Oh, my gosh, that's pretty easy.
我们要登上舞台。没错，没错，没错。如果你还没买票，就去smartless.com/live，对吧？等等，是什么？Smartless.com/live。天哪，那挺简单的。
And for that, they're going to get a double guest. Is that right? Yep. Two guests. And we got some fun, we got some fun surprises. Yeah. Really? Yeah, we got some fun surprises.
而且在那场演出中，他们会看到双嘉宾。对吧？没错。两位嘉宾。我们还有一些有趣的惊喜。真的吗？是的，我们准备了一些有趣的惊喜。
All for the price of one ticket. Yeah, all for the price of one ticket. And a nice, beautiful. October 17th, right? A fall night out there under the stars. It's going to be gorgeous. And yeah, you buy a ticket and you can't put a price tag on a smile. Oh, what a great sell.
全都是一张票的价格。没错，全都是一张票的价格。而且是在一个美好、漂亮的夜晚。10月17日，对吧？秋天的夜晚，在星空下。一定会非常棒。而且，你买了一张票，笑容是无价的。哦，多棒的推销啊。
You know? Will, you're the best. Anyway, it's going to be a great night, hopefully as great as this next guest coming up. Guys, let's get to the episode. You can hear me now? There he is. Listener and guest.
你知道吗？威尔，你是最棒的。总之，那会是一个很棒的夜晚，希望和接下来要出场的这位嘉宾一样棒。伙计们，让我们进入正题吧。现在能听到我说话吗？他来了。听众兼嘉宾。
You've just been, you've just been, You spent all night on your computer in incognito mode for, we don't know why. But we just... I had to change all my settings and all my usernames. Sorry. If you got hacked, it would be the most boring hack for a hacker. It would just be all baseball stats. And list of, like, movie stuff.
你刚才，你刚才，你整晚都在电脑上用无痕模式，我们不知道为什么。但我们只是……我不得不更改了我所有的设置和所有的用户名。抱歉。如果你被黑了，那对黑客来说将是最无聊的黑客攻击。那里面全是棒球数据。还有电影之类的列表。
Yeah. You know, when I get all the cookie alerts, you know, would you like to reject all cookies or whatnot? And I do. I do reject them. I know Sean, you don't. Quick question, Sean, have you ever? Yeah. Yeah, I beat you.
是啊。你知道，当我收到所有的Cookie提醒时，你知道，你想拒绝所有Cookie还是其他什么？我确实拒绝了。我知道肖恩，你不会。问个快问题，肖恩，你有没有？是啊。是啊，我打败你了。
But I don't have any secrets. And, you know, so like my instinct is to accept the cookies because then I don't get ads for things that I don't need. You know, like, you know, skin, skin rashes and things like that. I get ads for. J.B., but you don't have secrets, but you don't have secrets, but you. You used to be, you, there was a time where you were just built on secrets. Yeah. Well, I, no, I think I was, I was, I was doing things at a time when we didn't have phones and things.
但我没有任何秘密。所以，我的直觉是接受Cookie，因为这样我就不会收到我不需要的广告。你知道，比如，皮肤皮疹之类的东西。我会收到广告。J.B.，但你没有秘密，但你没有秘密，但你……你曾经，你曾经有一段时间，你整个人就是建立在秘密之上的。是啊。嗯，我，不，我想我当时，我当时，我当时做那些事的时候，我们还没有手机之类的东西。
I know. Yeah, yeah, yeah, I know. To photograph us. And even then, I wasn't, I was, I was never a bad boy. It's so boring. Come on. Even my bad days were boring. When you say bad boy, like the idea of you, like, like in a leather jacket, and then you flip the collar up, you know.
我知道。是啊，是啊，是啊，我知道。来拍我们。即便如此，我也不是，我从来都不是个坏小子。太无聊了。得了吧。即使是我糟糕的日子也很无聊。当你提到坏小子时，就像你那种形象，穿着皮夹克，然后把领子竖起来，你知道的。
Yeah. Or, like, could you imagine? me ever trying to mix it up with like a paparazzi guy that gets too close to my face and I take a swing and I'm like Sean Penn and then I just get my ass beaten you know repeatedly I can see I could actually see that wait have you ever owned a leather jacket quickly either of you of course yeah yeah yeah I have but they were they were they were soft and swayed they weren't even like manly lambskin mine was lamb skin back in the 80s and no no I'm saying leather jacket yeah oh I see okay okay I think had like a veal skin vest
是啊。或者，你能想象吗？我试图和一个靠我脸太近的狗仔队发生冲突，我挥了一拳，就像肖恩·潘那样，然后我被揍得屁滚尿流，你知道的，反复地。我能想象，我真的能想象。等等，你们俩谁曾经拥有过皮夹克吗？当然，是啊，是啊，我有，但它们是，它们是，它们是柔软的麂皮，甚至不像那种男人的羊羔皮。我的是80年代的羊羔皮，不，不，我说的是皮夹克，是啊。哦，我明白了，好吧，好吧。我想我有一件小牛皮背心。
yeah veled velcro closers on it tonight we got a beautiful veal skin what else we got chef is preparing a beautiful veal skin yeah now uh
是啊，上面有魔术贴。今晚我们有一件漂亮的小牛皮，我们还有什么？厨师正在准备一件漂亮的小牛皮，是啊，现在，呃。
will uh yeah I feel like it's been a while since we've had an update on your on your love life and domestic life no we're not doing this what's going on there we always talk about Sean and I's personal life what about what's going on with your personal life
威尔，呃，是啊，我觉得我们很久没有听到关于你的爱情生活和家庭生活的更新了。不，我们不谈这个。那里发生了什么？我们总是谈论肖恩和我的私生活，你的私生活怎么样了？
What's going on, Will? It's going really well. Oh, that's nice? Yeah. What's happening? First of all, talk about secrets. Talk about secrets. Yeah, what are the deeds on that?
发生了什么，威尔？进展非常顺利。哦，那很好？是啊。发生了什么？首先，谈谈秘密。谈谈秘密。是啊，那方面的细节是什么？
Both of you know exactly what's happening and this is just, I'm not going to walk into your track. You're happy. You're happy? I'm very happy. Okay, so things are going great. Things are going great. You know, I've... Hold on, let me lead the witness.
你们俩都知道发生了什么，这只是，我不会掉进你们的圈套。你很幸福。你很幸福吗？我非常幸福。好吧，所以事情进展得很顺利。事情进展得很顺利。你知道，我……等等，让我引导一下证人。
Things are trending north, yeah? You know, the relationship is still ascendant? Yes. Yes. Okay. And if that were to continue to go on the course that it's going, at the angle, it is currently headed, where does that go? Yeah.
事情正在向好的方向发展，对吧？你知道，这段关系还在上升期？是的。是的。好吧。如果它继续按照目前的轨道，按照它目前前进的角度，它会走向哪里？是啊。
Well, first of all, why are you leading, why am I in court? Why are you leaving? Please answer the question, sir. Permission to treat the witness as hostile. Yeah. I mean, look, it will be a perfect world in five years. What does this relationship look like? Can I be honest with you?
嗯，首先，你为什么要引导，我为什么在法庭上？你为什么要离开？请回答问题，先生。请求将证人视为敌意证人。是啊。我的意思是，看，五年后会是一个完美的世界。这段关系看起来会是什么样？我能对你诚实吗？
If I fucking knew what five years, I am now at 56, I have learned a little bit, in the last two years especially, to let go of whatever ideas that I think it's going to go or it's going to happen. As we know, you get dealt so many fucking curveballs. And so I'm in a place now where I'm really trying my best to just deal with what's in front of me
如果我他妈的知道五年后会怎样，我现在56岁了，我学到了一点，特别是在过去两年里，学会了放下任何我认为它会走向哪里或会发生什么的念头。正如我们所知，你会遇到那么多他妈的变数。所以我现在处于一个位置，我真的在尽我所能去处理眼前的事情。
and to try to take the next best. But you don't want to be fully reactive to everything in your life. You do like to be proactive in some areas, right? and kind of have the car moving in a particular direction? Well, for me that has been in the last couple of years, as both of you know, trying my best to lay a great foundation. I surround myself with great people. I'm in great programs with people.
并尝试采取下一步最好的行动。但你不想对生活中的一切都完全被动。你确实喜欢在某些领域主动，对吧？并且让车朝着特定的方向行驶？嗯，对我来说，在过去几年里，正如你们俩所知，我尽我所能打下了一个坚实的基础。我身边都是很棒的人。我参加了很棒的项目，和很棒的人在一起。
I've done some work on myself to try to do it in a way so that whatever does come my way, I handle it hopefully better than I have historically. Right. Yeah, yeah. Prosecution rest. Hey, you know what? Let's get to our guest, huh?
我对自己做了一些工作，试图以一种方式去做，这样无论发生什么，我都能处理得比过去更好。对。是啊，是啊。控方休息。嘿，你知道吗？让我们进入我们的嘉宾环节吧，好吗？
Okay. Dr. Ruth Westheimer is on the show today to walk will through. You know what? Let's see. He might have a Dr. Ruth. He might have an opinion on Dr. Ruth. I don't know. He's got opinions on lots of stuff, and I like his opinions on most of stuff. He lands on the right side of virtually every issue I think I've ever had a conversation with him. Right, meaning correct? Correct, funny, insightful, and well, he's well educated, he's super smart. He's got 35 Emmy nominations to back it up.
好的。露丝·韦斯特海默博士今天来到节目中，引导威尔。你知道吗？让我们看看。他可能对露丝博士有看法。他可能对露丝博士有意见。我不知道。他对很多事情都有意见，而且我喜欢他对大多数事情的看法。我觉得我跟他谈过的几乎每一个问题，他都站在正确的一边。对，意思是正确的？正确、有趣、有洞察力，而且，他受过良好的教育，他超级聪明。他有35项艾美奖提名作为后盾。
He's hosted the Golden Globes. He's hosted the Emmys. He's produced shows. He was a cast member of S&L for 13 years. He was the co-host of Weekend Update for eight years with my ex-wife and our old friend, Amy Poehler. You guys. It's Seth Meyer. Seth Meyer.
他主持过金球奖。他主持过艾美奖。他制作过节目。他是《周六夜现场》13年的演员。他和我的前妻以及我们的老朋友艾米·波勒一起主持了八年的《周末更新》。伙计们。是塞斯·梅耶斯。塞斯·梅耶斯。
Oh, gentlemen. This is our old. The right-wing pundits. He's been taking notes. Thank you for Claire. find the right side of every issue. I was like, okay, well, that means this was thrilling, just the pre-show banter.
哦，先生们。这是我们的老朋友。右翼权威人士。他一直在做笔记。谢谢克莱尔。找到每个问题的正确一面。我当时想，好吧，那意味着这太令人兴奋了，仅仅是演出前的闲聊。
And, you know, again, anybody listens to this show here is the pre-show banter, but I bet that, again, I'm now new to the podcast game compared to you guys. It's dead easy. It's thrilling to find out the tech doesn't get sorted out. No, yeah. It's just, I mean, if you guys could hear the three of them try to get ready for a podcast
而且，你知道，再说一次，任何听这个节目的人都知道演出前的闲聊，但我敢打赌，再说一次，与你们相比，我现在是播客界的新手。这太容易了。发现技术问题没有解决，这很令人兴奋。不，是啊。我的意思是，如果你们能听到他们三个人试图为播客做准备。
they've done over 300, I was Googling how many episodes you were doing over the course of... Should I shut down or reset? Should I reboot or shut down? Jason, at one point you said, can I hear me? You asked the other two guys. Can I hear me? That's our new T-shirt and our swag.
他们已经做了300多集了，我当时在谷歌搜索你们在过去……我应该关闭还是重置？我应该重启还是关机？杰森，有一次你说，我能听到我说话吗？你问另外两个人。我能听到我说话吗？那是我们的新T恤和周边。
I can't wait to tell the Lonely Island guys, it does not get easier. It does not get smoother. We're all ding-dongs. If anything, he gets harder. My favorite thing about when Jason, when he has to reboot and when it's not working and he can't hear the headphones, is his face because he's in the,
我迫不及待地想告诉孤独岛乐队的伙计们，这并不会变得更容易。这并不会变得更顺畅。我们都是笨蛋。如果说有什么不同的话，那就是变得更难了。关于杰森，当他不得不重启，当它不起作用，当他听不到耳机里的声音时，我最喜欢的是他的表情，因为他处于……
so he's not. aware of his face. So he's looking and he's like my dad with the remote and somebody has changed the input. Forget it. And somehow we feel like if we get closer to the object that's troubling us, it'll become fixed. Just get your face closer to it. We're all at the age now. We're at certain angles we look like a 70-year-old aunt's.
所以他没有意识到自己的表情。所以他看着，就像我爸爸拿着遥控器，有人改了输入源。算了吧。而且不知何故，我们觉得如果我们离困扰我们的物体更近一点，它就会修好。只要把你的脸靠近它就行了。我们现在都到了这个年纪，在某些角度我们看起来像70岁的阿姨。
You know what I mean? And it's usually when we're trying to figure out, again, we're all, it's like in the cheater zone, I'm there too. were just certain angles. Somehow I always seem to have my jaw somewhat separated and people say they take these pictures of me, Will, as guilty of this, my wife a lot, taking pictures of me with my, and Jimmy, Kimmel and Molly,
你知道我的意思吗？通常当我们试图弄清楚时，再说一次，我们都在，就像在老花镜区，我也在那里。只是某些角度。不知何故，我的下巴似乎总是有点分开，人们说他们拍了这些我的照片，威尔对此有罪，我妻子经常拍我，还有吉米·坎摩尔和莫莉。
my mouth just slightly open and I'm staring off into space or I'm laughing with my mouth sort of a gape. So yeah, it's sort of, it's a sign of old age coming in, I think. I do think I've crossed the threshold with my wife where if I see her taken out of her phone to take a picture of me, it means that something's gone terribly wrong. Something's not right on my face. No, you just reach the point where it's not like,
我的嘴微微张开，我盯着虚空，或者我张着嘴大笑。所以是的，这有点，我认为这是衰老的迹象。我确实认为我已经跨过了我妻子的门槛，如果我看到她拿出手机拍我，这意味着出了什么大问题。我的脸上有什么不对劲。不，你只是到了那个点，不是说……
I need pictures of my husband looking handsome or good. Something they can send to their friends and laugh at. Yeah, yeah, yeah. They're so mean. Seth, dude, this has been so long overdue. I feel like we talked about this last fall. I'm so happy to be here. We talked about it last.
我需要我丈夫看起来英俊或好看的照片。他们可以发给朋友嘲笑的东西。是啊，是啊，是啊。她们太刻薄了。塞斯，伙计，这真的拖得太久了。我觉得我们去年秋天就谈过这个。我很高兴来到这里。我们上次谈过。
I ran into you during trick-or-treat. last fall in New York in the middle of mayhem in the West Village. Wait, how does that go? That's just purely, that's just elevator riding, correct? It was really exciting.
去年秋天我在纽约不给糖就捣蛋的时候遇到了你，在西村的混乱中。等等，那是怎么回事？那只是乘电梯，对吧？那真的很令人兴奋。
We had two great run-ins in the course of like three months. One was just West Village, packed West Village. Perfect place to take your kids trick-or-treating in New York City. But otherwise, otherwise, it's in apartment buildings usually though, right?
我们在三个月内有两次很棒的偶遇。一次只是西村，拥挤的西村。在纽约市带孩子去不给糖就捣蛋的完美地方。但除此之外，除此之外，通常是在公寓楼里，对吧？
I mean, you're going up and down an elevator. But this is people, no, this is now people sitting on Brownstone Steps. And they close down the streets and it is a real great community vibe. It is. You know, my kids, we saw Will, we saw Alec Baldwin and half a Telatubby costume.
我的意思是，你上下电梯。但这是人们，不，这是人们坐在褐砂石台阶上。他们封锁了街道，这是一种非常棒的社区氛围。确实。你知道，我的孩子们，我们看到了威尔，我们看到了亚历克·鲍德温穿着半套天线宝宝服装。
Sure. With like four of his six kids and just kind of like trying to get. And were you guys dressed up? Matthew Broderick. I love Matthew. What's that? We were, I was not dressed up.
当然。带着他六个孩子中的四个，只是试图去……你们打扮了吗？马修·布罗德里克。我爱马修。那是什么？我们，我没有打扮。
Will, I don't think. No. We were, we were, yeah. No, we were... We still wanted to be recognized for our work. We were trying to draw attention to IP that we didn't own. I was wearing a T-shirt, I said, I think that said, ask me if I'm Will Arnett.
威尔，我不认为。不。我们，我们，是啊。不，我们……我们仍然希望因为我们的工作而被认可。我们试图引起人们对我们不拥有的知识产权的关注。我当时穿着一件T恤，我想上面写着，问我是不是威尔·阿奈特。
Is that right? Yeah, that was... Wait, and then, and then we were in... Oh, I got to get that. I was in London having dinner with Laura Dern and Mark Chappell, and Rashida walked by. Rashida Jones. And she was like, hey, guys, and we were in the...
是这样吗？是啊，那是……等等，然后，然后我们在……哦，我得弄到那个。我在伦敦和劳拉·邓恩以及马克·查佩尔吃晚饭，拉什达走过。拉什达·琼斯。她说，嘿，伙计们，我们在……
front and she goes, I'm here with Seth, and I went back and you were sitting by yourself, and I said, we're over here, and you guys came and joined us, and we had a very fun, impromptu night at a restaurant in London. Guys. It was great. You're selling yourself short because you first came over, and I was, you know, Rashida had gone
前面，她说，我和塞斯在一起，我回去了，你一个人坐着，我说，我们在这边，你们过来加入了我们，我们在伦敦的一家餐馆度过了一个非常有趣、即兴的夜晚。伙计们。太棒了。你太谦虚了，因为你第一次过来的时候，我当时，你知道拉什达去。
to use the restroom, so I was just looking at my phone like everybody would do, and you came over to take my order. And so I had a moment where... That's funny. It was a... It was jarring. And then lovely. Well, because you didn't, you didn't, you, you hadn't seen me since Halloween. You're like, in that time, he's now working at the Dover in London. Yeah.
上洗手间了，所以我只是像每个人一样看着手机，你过来点餐。所以我有一个时刻……那很有趣。那是一个……令人震惊的。然后很可爱。嗯，因为你没有，你没有，你，你从万圣节开始就没见过我。你就像，在那段时间里，他现在在伦敦的多佛工作。是啊。
And like I said, you never know what life's going to throw at you. Yeah. Because I said on Halloween, I'm like, what are you up to now? And you're like, I've got some irons in the fire. I did say that. Did you guys ever go through a table waiting period of your lives? Oh, yeah. Yeah.
就像我说的，你永远不知道生活会给你带来什么。是啊。因为我在万圣节说，我问你现在在忙什么？你说，我手头有一些事情在进行。我确实那么说了。你们有没有经历过人生中等待餐桌的时期？哦，是啊。是啊，当然。
Yeah, for sure. I was at the Twisted Lizard in Chicago, which closed it. in the last five years, but I was, yeah, that was in my early improv days, and I remember the most memorable moment was I, it was a downstairs, you took stairs down, and I remember once getting no tip and chasing a guy out
我当时在芝加哥的Twisted Lizard，它在过去五年里关门了，但我当时，是啊，那是在我早期的即兴表演时期，我记得最难忘的时刻是我，那是楼下，你走楼梯下去，我记得有一次没收到小费，追着一个家伙出去。
and asking why he didn't leave me a tip, and he said, because you're a bad waiter. No way. He said that. Which is basically, historically what that means. I needed to, I needed to make him tell me twice. I don't bet in your defense you probably said, fair enough.
问他为什么没给我小费，他说，因为你是个糟糕的服务员。没门。他那么说了。这基本上，从历史上看，这意味着什么。我需要，我需要让他再说一遍。我不认为在你的辩护中你可能会说，有道理。
Yeah, I was, yeah, I did not fight it after that. I was like, oh, I thought it was an oversight. It's tough to argue. I mean, you can, I mean, theoretically you could have said, well, in what, in what way? You know what I mean? But at that point, there's no point. I think also, as soon as he said that, I looked back and saw about six or seven things I could have done differently. Right.
是啊，我当时，是啊，在那之后我没有反驳。我当时想，哦，我以为是疏忽。很难争论。我的意思是，你可以，我的意思是，理论上你可以说，嗯，以什么方式？你知道我的意思吗？但在那个时候，没有意义。我想也是，当他那么说的时候，我回头看了一下，看到了大约六七件我可以做得不同的事情。对。
Now, let me ask you guys this. I'm not sure if this is the most relatable part of this interview, but in Europe, fellas, you're not supposed to leave a tip. Is that correct? I always get tripped up on this. It's changed. It's kind of changed. What is it now? You do.
现在，让我问你们这个问题。我不确定这是否是这次采访中最能引起共鸣的部分，但在欧洲，伙计们，你不应该给小费。对吗？我总是被这个问题绊倒。它变了。它有点变了。现在是什么？你确实给。
You do leave a tip, but is it like... If you're American, you do. Yeah, yeah. The hope is you think about how much of your work has gone international. Yes. And whether or not they'll be able to... Word of mouth will be able to get out that you're a bad tip. That's the calculation.
你确实给小费，但它是……如果你是美国人，你确实给。是啊，是啊。希望是你考虑一下你的工作有多少已经走向国际。是的。以及他们是否能够……口碑是否能传出去你是个糟糕的小费给付者。这就是计算。
I used to be a runner. Remember the restaurant red in L.A.? Remember that? No. No. Cornice on Beverly. I was a runner there. Wait, was it in parentheses?
我曾经是个传菜员。记得洛杉矶的Red餐馆吗？记得吗？不。不。比佛利山庄的Cornice。我在那里做传菜员。等等，它在括号里吗？
No, it was bright red on the outside. It was called red. And they had great turkey meatloaf. But anyway, so I would run, I would be a runner, not even a waiter. And I had the one joke ready, every single table. They would say, you know, I'd have three plates. I'd like, great, blah, blah, blah. And inevitably, I'd put it down in front of somebody and they'd go, well, that looks fantastic.
不，它外面是亮红色的。它叫Red。他们有很棒的火鸡肉饼。但总之，所以我跑，我会做传菜员，甚至不是服务员。我准备了一个笑话，每一张桌子。他们会说，你知道，我有三个盘子。我喜欢，太棒了，等等等等。不可避免地，我会把它放在某人面前，他们会说，嗯，看起来棒极了。
And I'd point to my shirt and I'd say, thanks, I just got it. What a joke. So wait, a runner is the person that brings the plates, doesn't take the order. Runs the food. Got it. Yeah, I couldn't. Red in parentheses, isn't red in parentheses Bono's like, humanitarian? Oh, okay, there you go.
我会指着我的衬衫说，谢谢，我刚买的。多烂的笑话。等等，传菜员是把盘子端上来，不点菜的人。跑菜的。明白了。是啊，我不能。Red在括号里，Red在括号里不是波诺的那个，人道主义的吗？哦，好吧，原来如此。
See how old I'm getting? It's also a nice burn on Sean. You're like, were you the one that was the humanitarian one? Okay, no, not at all. Yeah, but I got yelled at all the time. Like, do you know where you're going? Do you know which table you're going? I'm like, no, I just look at that table.
看看我老成什么样了？这对肖恩也是一个很好的讽刺。你就像，你是那个做人道主义的人吗？好吧，不，一点也不。是啊，但我一直被骂。比如，你知道你要去哪里吗？你知道你要去哪张桌子吗？我当时想，不，我只是看着那张桌子。
And then you had to memorize the seats where everybody was sitting, not only the 70 tables. It was hard. I'm just curious. How long did you work there, Sean? About a year. Okay. And it was just the one joke.
然后你必须记住每个人坐在哪里的座位，不仅仅是70张桌子。很难。我只是好奇。肖恩，你在那里工作了多久？大约一年。好的。而且只是那个笑话。
Just the one joke, yeah. Like you never decided to punch it up or just... No, he kept refining it. Yeah, yeah. It was good, though. And they never gave you the promotion up a level. No, I asked, too, to be a waiter, but I couldn't. Oh, look at you know.
只是那个笑话，是啊。就像你从来没决定把它改进一下或者只是……不，他一直在精炼它。是啊，是啊。不过挺好的。而且他们从来没给你升职。不，我也问过，想做服务员，但我不能。哦，看看你。
I had more stress dreams about being a waiter than I did. Yeah, there's too much. Remember squirrel? Remember the program called Squirrel on the computer, which they would punch in, the waiters would punch it in? Oh, right, right. Anybody? No. Okay. Okay, great.
我做关于做服务员的压力梦比我做的……是啊，太多了。记得Squirrel吗？记得电脑上那个叫Squirrel的程序吗，服务员会把它输入进去？哦，对，对。有人吗？不。好的。好的，太棒了。
And you'd slide your card in to open up. On the POS? Was that squirrel in parentheses? No, no. All right, Seth, speaking of starting out, let's talk about how you started out. We got to go. All right, cue the music.
然后你会插入你的卡来打开。在POS机上？那是括号里的Squirrel吗？不，不。好了，塞斯，说到开始，让我们谈谈你是怎么开始的。我们得走了。好的，播放音乐。
Yeah, cue the music. You're from New Hampshire, but we all know you're a Steelers fan, and we don't need to get into that. We know, right? That's fine. If you want to... That's fine. If you want to stop just for one second.
是啊，播放音乐。你来自新罕布什尔州，但我们都知道你是钢人队的球迷，我们不需要讨论那个。我们知道，对吧？没关系。如果你想……没关系。如果你想停一下，就一秒钟。
I will just tell you this real quick. Yesterday, my 10-year-old son was on the phone with my 78-year-old father talking about the Steelers' first preseason game, and I genuinely wanted to just go sit in a corner and sob. It made me so happy. Because it's just empty nonsense, no-calorie conversation, but the connection is real. And it was just like my son saying things like,
我很快告诉你这个。昨天，我10岁的儿子和我78岁的父亲在电话里谈论钢人队的季前赛第一场比赛，我真诚地想去角落里坐着啜泣。这让我太开心了。因为这只是空洞的废话，没有营养的对话，但这种联系是真实的。就像我儿子说的话，比如，
I think Jeremy Bernard is probably, our third best receiver. And I'm like, great. Yeah. But now Aaron Rogers is the quarterback again, correct? Yes, Aaron Rogers is the start. And he's also the chief scientist, I think, isn't he? He is.
我想杰里米·伯纳德可能是，我们第三好的接球手。我当时想，太棒了。是啊。但现在阿隆·罗杰斯又是四分卫了，对吧？是的，阿隆·罗杰斯是首发。而且他也是首席科学家，我想，不是吗？他是。
He's taken over science for most of Pittsburgh, I think. And does he get to eat earlier because he's a senior? Or does he eat with the rest of the team? Oh, that's a good question. I believe he does. There's still certain places. Wait, how old is Aaron Lenders? 43 years old.
我想他接管了匹兹堡大部分的科学。他因为是长辈所以能吃得更早吗？还是他和球队其他人一起吃？哦，那是个好问题。我相信他会的。仍然有某些地方。等等，阿隆·罗杰斯多大了？43岁。
And he's... And you're just, that's very old for football. Yeah, not alive. Young for podcasts. It's true. You bet your ass. You know what? I will say, though, I connect with my dad.
而且他……而且你只是，这对橄榄球来说太老了。是啊，没活着。对播客来说很年轻。是真的。你敢肯定。你知道吗？不过，我会说，我和我爸爸有联系。
I'm a long-suffering Toronto Maple Leafs fan. And my dad and I, often, you know, he's about to be 88. And we talk about the Leafs. That's our sort of point. We talk about lots of other stuff, too. But that is the thing that we can talk about on a daily basis. You know, we can just. just sort of have a, hey, they look terrible last night,
我是多伦多枫叶队长期受苦的球迷。我和我爸爸经常，你知道，他快88岁了。我们谈论枫叶队。那是我们的某种观点。我们也谈论很多其他事情。但那是我们可以每天谈论的事情。你知道，我们可以只是。只是有一种，嘿，他们昨晚看起来很糟糕，
what's going on, all that kind of stuff. And it keeps us connected in that way. As you say, it's light on calories, but it's very filling. So, Seth, you're high. Wait, so, Seth, you come out of, you're fighting out of New Hampshire, and you decide what is the thing, how do you, you went to Northwestern. Is that where you started writing and or performing comedy,
发生了什么，所有那种事情。它以那种方式保持我们的联系。正如你所说，它热量很低，但非常充实。所以，塞斯，你很高。等等，所以，塞斯，你从新罕布什尔州出来，你决定什么是那件事，你怎么，你去了西北大学。那是你开始写作和/或表演喜剧的地方吗，
or were you doing it before in New Hampshire? I was softly doing it in college. I'm sorry, in high school, I remember we did a comedy night in high school where we sort of rode sketches. We were doing, you know, B-minus impressions of teachers and stuff, but it was really fun. But I went to college to be a film major,
还是你在新罕布什尔州之前就做过了？我在大学里轻轻地做过。抱歉，在高中，我记得我们在高中举办了一个喜剧之夜，我们写了一些小品。我们当时在做，你知道，B减的老师模仿之类的，但这真的很有趣。但我上大学是为了成为电影专业，
thought I wanted to write and direct movies, and Northwestern has this very famous... So many people go, I know, they go there. Yeah. And then it's a meow, is this very... I think the first improv troupe at any college, and it's been around forever. And that was immediately what I wanted to do. I saw them my first week.
以为我想写和导演电影，而西北大学有这个非常著名的……很多人去那里，我知道。是啊。然后是Meow，这是非常……我想是任何大学的第一个即兴表演团，而且它已经存在很久了。那是我第一周就想做的事情。
Did you do any second city while you were in Chicago? After college, that was my goal. I only did me out for one year, but that was all I wanted to do, was to do Second City. And I had seen a lot of Second City. My parents went to Northwestern. They'd seen a lot of Second City.
你在芝加哥的时候做过第二城吗？大学毕业后，那是我的目标。我只做了一年Meow，但那是我唯一想做的，就是做第二城。而且我看了很多第二城。我父母去了西北大学。他们看了很多第二城。
I remember when we went and looked at Northwestern, my dad brought me to Second City, and we saw young Carrel, young Colbert on stage together. Wow. Yeah. And so that's all I wanted to do. So that was post-college.
我记得当我们去西北大学看的时候，我爸爸带我去了第二城，我们看到年轻的卡瑞尔，年轻的科尔伯特在舞台上一起表演。哇。是啊，所以那是我唯一想做的。所以那是大学毕业后。
That was Weight and Tables at the Twisted Lizard. And there was that weird thing. You just kind of improvise. I was doing stuff at Improv Olympic now called I-O, but waiting for that sort of biannual audition where everybody would go in and audition for Second City. But that's all I was looking at was that. Right.
那是Twisted Lizard的等待餐桌。而且有那种奇怪的事情。你只是即兴发挥。我现在在做即兴奥林匹克，现在叫I-O，但等待那种半年一次的试镜，每个人都会去参加第二城的试镜。但我唯一关注的就是那个。对。
And we will be right back. And now back to the show. So you saw those guys like Correll and those guys when you went, as you said, with your dad. And then once you got to Improv Olympic at post-college, who are the people, because there's so many different classes, of people who were kind of in and around. So many names we all know, right?
我们马上回来。现在回到节目。所以你看到了像卡瑞尔那些人，当你去的时候，正如你所说，和你爸爸一起。然后一旦你到了大学后的即兴奥林匹克，谁是那些人，因为有这么多不同的班级，人们有点在周围。我们都知道这么多名字，对吧？
You included who came through that Chicago thing. Who were the people who were sort of your contemporaries at the time? Well, it's so nuts because it was genuinely I was present during a scene. Like I'm not being part of it, but it was like, oh, this is what like a scene is like where everybody, you knew you were in the right place because there had been this wave of people were just leaving, you know, like Brian Stack and Brian McCann like to go to Conan stuff, Dorff. So they were the slightly older.
包括你，经历过芝加哥那件事的人。谁是当时你的同龄人？嗯，这太疯狂了，因为我确实在现场。就像我不是其中的一部分，但就像，哦，这就是场景的样子，每个人，你知道你在正确的地方，因为有一波人刚刚离开，你知道，比如布莱恩·斯塔克和布莱恩·麦肯去柯南节目，多夫。所以他们是稍微年长一点的。
And then there was, you know, in John Glazer. And then there was, you know, Tina and Amy and Horatio and Dratch. So that was all the people that you would either go see at Second City or sometimes they would just pop in to Improv Olympic. You guys know that game, the dream, where you bring somebody up and you ask about their day and then you improvise a dream about it. I remember just once being in the audience,
然后有，你知道，约翰·格雷泽。然后有，你知道，蒂娜和艾米，还有霍拉肖和德拉奇。所以那些是你要么去第二城看，要么有时他们只是会出现在即兴奥林匹克的人。你们知道那个游戏，梦，你把某人带上来，问他们的一天，然后即兴表演一个关于它的梦。我记得有一次在观众席，
the first time I talked to Amy, She brought me on stage and she asked me about my day. And then that, like her cohort did basically improvised a sketch about what my dream would be based on the day I had. So it was really amazing to feel very confident, not in how it was going to turn out, but very confident. This is the right place to be at this moment if you want to be in comedy. But did that, did the confidence you feel about, well, I kind of would like to do this more than, your film goals, did you go all in on that as far as what your career
第一次我和艾米说话，她把我带上舞台，问我的一天。然后那个，像她的同伙基本上即兴表演了一个小品，关于我的梦会是什么，基于我度过的一天。所以感觉非常自信真的很棒，不是关于它会变成什么样，而是非常自信。如果你想从事喜剧，此时此刻这就是正确的地方。但那种自信，关于，嗯，我有点想做这个，超过你的电影目标，你是否全力以赴，关于你的职业
and path to making a living would be? Or were you studying something else simultaneously to mitigate your risk? You know, I got, immediately my takeaway on film class was, oh my God, this is so scientific. And I don't think I have the, you know, where I just don't think I have the attention span for this
和谋生的道路？还是你同时在学习其他东西来降低风险？你知道，我得到了，我电影课的收获立刻就是，天哪，这太科学了。而且我不认为我有，你知道，我只是不认为我有那种注意力跨度，
and the amount of lighting and the 180 degree rule and lenses. I was like, well, this is the snooze. And so I started, there was a creative writing for the media sort of sub-major, and I was doing that. But, you know, half, I would say most of those people as soon as they graduated, went out to L.A. They wrote spec scripts and they went to L.A. where, you know, Sean, you know, there's a ton of Northwestern people out there. Yeah, so many.
以及灯光和180度规则和镜头的数量。我当时想，好吧，这真是无聊。所以我开始，有一个媒体创意写作的子专业，我当时在做那个。但是，你知道，一半，我会说大多数人在毕业后立刻就去了洛杉矶。他们写剧本，他们去了洛杉矶，你知道，肖恩，你知道，那里有大量的西北大学的人。是啊，太多了。
And certainly, you know, when I graduated in the, you know, mid-90s, like there was just, this, you know, Northwestern Mafia out there. And so there were plenty of connections, but by the time I graduated, I wanted to improvise and do comedy more than I wanted to make or write films. But you had no backup career aside from, I mean, you were confident
当然，你知道，当我毕业时，在90年代中期，就像有这个，你知道，西北大学黑手党在那里。所以有很多联系，但当我毕业时，我想即兴表演和做喜剧，超过我想制作或写电影。但你除了，我的意思是，你很自信
that the entertainment industry was going to be something you were going to be able to make a living in. No backup, correct. I got a weird job, like a weird, early tech job right out of college where I worked for two months for a friend of mine who had started, the idea was it was a, you would get free minutes for your phone long distance,
娱乐业是你能够谋生的东西，没有后备职业。没有后备，正确。我得到了一份奇怪的工作，就像一份奇怪的早期科技工作，大学毕业后，我为一个朋友工作了两个月，他开始了，想法是，你会为你的手机长途电话获得免费分钟，
but you would have to listen to a commercial before you placed an ad. I'm sorry, before you placed a call. It's not a bad idea. It's basically like what tech again? Wait a second. Keep selling me. So you're interested. But I worked for two months there.
但你必须在拨打电话之前听一段广告。抱歉，在你拨打电话之前。这不是个坏主意。它基本上就像科技再次？等等。继续推销我。所以你感兴趣。但我为他工作了两个月。
I was like the seventh hire, and I remember he came in one day. He's like, so nobody thinks you want to be here. And I was like, you know what? I don't. And he's like, yeah, that's kind of what we thought. But they, I will say I had really, my friend group at Northwestern, which were not all comedy or theater people,
我是第七个雇员，我记得他有一天进来。他说，所以没人认为你想在这里。我当时想，你知道吗？我不想。他说，是啊，那正是我们所想的。但他们，我会说我确实有，我在西北大学的朋友圈，那不是所有的喜剧或戏剧人，
they were all really supportive. Everybody was like, yeah, I mean, don't, you should just try that. Yeah, that's all you seem to be interested. But you know, it brings up, I was having this conversation with somebody the other day, which was like, I think, you know, every once in a while somebody will call you and say, like, hey, my son is graduating college or they're trying to get into entertainment. Can they call you?
他们都非常支持。每个人都说，是啊，我的意思是，别，你应该试试那个。是啊，那似乎是你唯一感兴趣的。但你知道，它提到了，我前几天和某人谈话，就像，我想，你知道，每隔一段时间就会有人打电话给你说，嘿，我儿子大学毕业了，或者他们想进入娱乐业。他们能打电话给你吗？
We've all had those calls. All the time. Yeah. Right? And so you end up talking to people, and I always think like there's no, what kind of advice can you give somebody? There's really no plan for it. It's not like law school where you say, finish law school here and then try to go and work for it. So there's not.
我们都接到过那些电话。一直。是啊。对吧？所以你最终和人们交谈，我总是想，就像没有，你能给某人什么建议？真的没有计划。它不像法学院，你说，在这里完成法学院，然后尝试去工作。所以没有。
But I remember the other day I saying to somebody like, you kind of can't have a backup plan. You have to be all in. It has to be, that's the risk is the thing. And it's because when you don't have anything to fall back on, it forces you. you to try to do whatever you can to get a job. And you're not going to hit necessarily. It's very rare that somebody hits it out of the park on their first job, and you're going to take a lot of shit jobs,
但我记得前几天我对某人说，就像你不能有后备计划。你必须全力以赴。它必须是，风险就是那件事。这是因为当你没有任何退路时，它会迫使你。你尝试做任何你能做的事情来得到一份工作。而且你不会一定成功。很少有人在第一份工作就大获成功，你会吃很多屎工作，
and you're going to do, I don't know, work background, or you're going to do whatever it is that you're going to do, but you have to be all in, I think. It is nice, though, that pursuing the entertainment industry at its early stage does lend itself to the schedule whereby you can hold down a job that can pay your rent and feed you, you know, all out waiting tables, or whatever it is.
你会做，我不知道，做背景工作，或者你会做任何你要做的事情，但我认为你必须全力以赴。不过，追求娱乐业在早期阶段确实有助于时间表，你可以保住一份能支付房租和养活你的工作，你知道，所有等待餐桌，或者无论是什么。
Sure. Right. But it is like that, I think when people talk about a plan B, you realize, you're like, you're gonna have a plan D. Yeah.
当然。对吧？但它确实是那样，我认为当人们谈论B计划时，你意识到，你就像，你会有D计划。是啊。
Yeah. You know, right? Which is like waiting tables. But like, when you talk about a plan B, like, what are you talking about? Because, you know, ultimately anybody who's plan A is your plan B
是啊。你知道，对吧？就像等待餐桌。但就像，当你谈论B计划时，就像，你在说什么？因为，你知道，最终任何A计划是你的B计划的人
is going to be so far ahead of you by the time you decide like that's what you want to do. Yes. It is, I mean, man, it is so nice to hear you say that, well, because I,
当你决定那正是你想要做的时候，他们会领先你那么多。是的。我的意思是，伙计，听到你这么说真是太好了，威尔，因为我，
the amount I feel like I am wasting everyone's time when they sit you down or get you on the phone with somebody who wants to talk about this business and the only thing you could say is like is if you have to only want to do it. Yes. That's the only way.
当他们让你坐下来或者通过电话联系到想要谈论这个行业的人时，我感觉我浪费了每个人的时间，而你唯一能说的就是，如果你必须只想做它。是的。那是唯一的方法。
If you're on the fence about like this in med school, I'd go to med school. You know what I mean? I'm like, yeah, don't look at me. I hopped, I pasted this thing together with scotch tape and rubber bands to get here. I don't know how, you know? Now what was Seth, what was Josh doing at this?
如果你在医学院这件事上犹豫不决，我会去医学院。你知道我的意思吗？我当时想，是啊，别看我。我用透明胶带和橡皮筋把这东西拼凑起来才到这里。我不知道怎么，你知道？现在塞斯，乔什当时在做什么？
Was he kind of like in a simple? similar track? Yeah, so the exact same track. Also Northwestern, also Meow. And then I had gotten... And he's two years, three years younger? Two years behind me in school. Yeah, two years exactly.
他是否有点像在简单的？类似的轨道？是啊，完全一样的轨道。也是西北大学，也是Meow。然后我得到了……而且他小两岁，三岁？比我低两届。是啊，正好两届。
And we... So then I got hired for this job in Amsterdam called Boom Chicago. So these Chicago guys, Northwestern guys, started basically a second city type theater in Amsterdam. And that was a thing I would never have done on my own. Sean's co-star, Peter Gross. Peter Gross, one of the funniest people of live. On Broadway and Good Night Oscar.
而且我们……所以我得到了这份在阿姆斯特丹的工作，叫Boom Chicago。所以这些芝加哥人，西北大学的人，基本上在阿姆斯特丹开了一家第二城类型的剧院。那是我自己永远不会做的事情。肖恩的联合主演，彼得·格罗斯。彼得·格罗斯，活着的最有趣的人之一。在百老汇和《晚安奥斯卡》。
He was my friend and he was, we had done improv together. We were improvising in Chicago together and he was the one who said, hey, there's this theater in Amsterdam and they're having auditions. And I just to this day, I'm so lucky to have had a friend who was willing to take a big swing like that
他是我的朋友，他是，我们一起做过即兴表演。我们在芝加哥一起即兴表演，他是那个说，嘿，阿姆斯特丹有这家剧院，他们在试镜。直到今天，我仍然很幸运有这样一个愿意冒大险的朋友
because I never would have even gone to that audition. But the fact that I had a friend, who was down for that kind of adventure, and we both auditioned for that, and then we both ended up moving to Amsterdam. I was there for two years. Am I right? Did Sadecas go to Boom Chicago after you?
因为我永远不会去参加那个试镜。但事实上我有一个朋友，愿意进行那种冒险，我们俩都去试镜了，然后我们俩最终都搬到了阿姆斯特丹。我在那里待了两年。我说的对吗？萨德卡斯在你之后去了Boom Chicago？
Is that right? Yeah, so Sadecas, it was a crazy... I mean, that was another time where I felt that thing of, like, being... I feel like we had another guest on this show that went to Amsterdam. I mean, anyway... You could have been Sadecas, Jordan Peel,
是这样吗？是啊，所以萨德卡斯，那是一个疯狂的……我的意思是，那是另一个我觉得那种感觉的时候，就像，被……我觉得我们在这个节目上有另一个嘉宾去了阿姆斯特丹。我的意思是，总之……你可能是萨德卡斯，乔丹·皮尔，
Ike Barrenholz. Oh, I think it was Ike. Oh, yeah. That's right. It was Ike. It was Ike. And, but it was another time where you're like, oh, we're part of a scene. Like, you just, where you look around and you're like, this is the place to be right now.
艾克·巴伦霍尔茨。哦，我想是艾克。哦，是啊。没错。是艾克。是艾克。而且，但那是另一个时候，你就像，哦，我们是场景的一部分。就像，你只是，当你环顾四周，你就像，这就是现在该去的地方。
And the hardest part about leaving to go do it was there was this idea that you were in line in Chicago. Whether you were or you weren't, you thought like, oh, my God, you know, I'm just going to spend six months getting closer to the kind of person that they'll hire for Second City and then I'll be a part of that organization. And so the risk we all had to do was leave and go do. this show in Amsterdam, but once you got there, you were performing way more than you would in Chicago, and you were living in fucking Amsterdam, and it was incredible. It was just the best done.
而且离开去做的最难的部分是，有一种想法是你排在芝加哥的队伍里。无论你是不是，你认为就像，哦，天哪，你知道，我只是要花六个月时间更接近那种他们会为第二城雇佣的人，然后我会成为那个组织的一部分。所以我们都必须冒的风险是离开，去做。这个在阿姆斯特丹的演出，但一旦你到了那里，你的表演比在芝加哥多得多，而且你住在该死的阿姆斯特丹，这太不可思议了。这只是最好的。
Because it's about time on stage. You need to have the hours. And we're getting to... Yeah, and so... By the way, Lord, the reason I was in London was, you know, they started us in O.C. And I had dinner with Lauren, and Lauren wanted me to go over there just to, like...
因为这是关于舞台上的时间。你需要有时间。我们正在进入……是啊，所以……顺便说一句，上帝，我之所以在伦敦是因为，你知道，他们让我们在O.C.开始。我和劳伦吃了晚饭，劳伦想让我去那边只是为了，就像……
It was before the show started, just to, like, sort of sit and talk to him. You know, and I think you're the right, one because, you know, Amsterdam. And I'm like, from 25 years ago? But also... Lauren, they don't even use the same money is when I live there.
在演出开始之前，只是为了，就像，坐下来和他谈谈。你知道，而且我认为你是对的，一个是，因为，你知道，阿姆斯特丹。而我，从25年前？但也……劳伦，他们甚至不使用和我住在那时一样的钱。
But by the way, what's kind of sweet about it is that he has these associations, he remembers that you came out of Amsterdam. Do you know what I mean? Yeah. And he, by the way, it's like, I think like the thing, Lauren is so, he gives way too much credit
但顺便说一句，有点甜蜜的是，他有这些联想，他记得你是从阿姆斯特丹出来的。你知道我的意思吗？是啊。而且他，顺便说一句，就像，我想就像那件事，劳伦太，他给了太多功劳
to living abroad and athletes. Like the amount people would audition for the show, give like the flattest audition, and Lauren would be like, you know, he played college at baseball, so you know he'll get it. But why? But then so, Seth,
给住在国外和运动员。就像人们试镜这个节目，给出最平淡的试镜，劳伦会说，你知道，他大学打棒球，所以你知道他会明白的。但为什么？但然后，塞斯，
so if everything went perfectly and one got recruited to Second City, is the next logical, you know, home run step after Second City Saturday Night Live? Is that the trajectory? Yeah, I mean, so that was the observable pipeline from the people that were, you know,
所以如果一切进展顺利，有人被第二城市剧团（Second City）录用了，那么继第二城市之后，下一个合乎逻辑的、你知道的，全垒打式的步骤是《周六夜现场》（SNL）吗？轨迹是这样的吗？是的，我是说，这就是从那些人身上观察到的路径，你知道的，
So, I mean, it was Jerry Minor. Before that was Tim Meadows. But I didn't really know him. But like Jerry Minor, Horatio Dratch, Tina. And then you just sort of thought like this, Adam McKay, you know, had gone there. And so that is, I think, why everybody wanted to be at Second City. And so then I spent two years in Amsterdam. I came back.
所以，我是说，那是杰瑞·迈纳（Jerry Minor）。在那之前是蒂姆·梅多斯（Tim Meadows）。但我不太认识他。但像杰瑞·迈纳、霍拉提奥·桑兹（Horatio Sanz）、蒂娜（Tina）。然后你就会觉得，亚当·麦凯（Adam McKay），你知道的，也去过那里。所以我认为这就是为什么每个人都想去第二城市的原因。然后我在阿姆斯特丹待了两年。我回来了。
Once again, my expectation was I'll get back in line. You know, maybe it's the end of the line. But this is still what I want. And then I had this crazy stroke of good fortune, which is this woman I.L. Cohen, who worked in the S&L Talent Department, came to this tiny little improv festival where my partner and I were doing a two-person show. And basically, I got to audition for S&L based off that.
再一次，我的期望是我会重新排队。你知道，也许这是队伍的末尾。但这仍然是我想要的。然后我有了这种疯狂的好运气，就是这位女士I.L.科恩（I.L. Cohen），她在SNL人才部门工作，她来到了这个微型即兴表演节，我和我的搭档在那里表演双人秀。基本上，我就是在那之后获得了为SNL试镜的机会。
And that's all to. And were you in any sports that Lauren recognized? Did you play sports or no? No. No, okay. No. All right. I desperately wanted to, and it was not to be it. Talk to me about how you became more interested, motivated, fulfilled, I'm assuming,
而这一切都是为了。你参加过洛恩（Lorne）认可的任何运动吗？你参加过体育运动吗，还是没有？没有。没有，好吧。没有。好吧。我非常想参加，但没能如愿。跟我说说你是如何变得更感兴趣、更有动力、更满足的，我假设，
with the writing track as opposed to the performing track. When did that start to take hold? Well, I mean, I would love to tell you that it was my instinct. But I think ultimately, and again, it worked out career-wise, so no regrets. Lorne made a mistake and should have hired me as a writer from that again. He hired me as a cat. member and I was then I mean again I was just it was a huge struggle for me to find a purchase and it only got worse I mean it was fine to be like all right you know I'm not obviously you know Will Farrell Tracy Morgan Chris Catan you know the people who are in the cast were older than me like nobody expected me to be better than them but then you know the next wave of people that came in you know then it's like sedacus hater right Fred and Will Bill and Ann and you're like, oh, no.
比起表演方向，你对写作方向更感兴趣？那是从什么时候开始的？嗯，我是说，我很想告诉你那是我的直觉。但我认为最终，而且再说一次，职业生涯发展得很顺利，所以没有遗憾。洛恩犯了个错误，本应该从一开始就雇我做编剧的。他雇我做演员，然后我，我是说，再次强调，我很难找到立足点，而且情况只会变得更糟。我是说，表现得像“好吧，你知道，我显然不是，你知道，威尔·法瑞尔（Will Ferrell）、崔西·摩根（Tracy Morgan）、克里斯·卡坦（Chris Kattan），你知道，那些演员比我年长，没有人指望我比他们更好”，这没问题。但后来，你知道，下一波进来的人，你知道，那是塞戴克斯（Sudeikis）、哈德（Hader），对吧，弗雷德（Fred）和威尔（Will）、比尔（Bill）和安（Ann），你会觉得，哦，不。
Like, they're like the younger cast members, but they're, you know, demonstrably better at sketch comedy than I am. And so I was sort of writing. I always loved writing, but at the time I was writing to stay alive more than anything else. Writing for yourself. Writing for myself.
就像，他们是更年轻的演员，但他们，你知道，在小品喜剧方面明显比我强。所以我当时在写东西。我一直很喜欢写作，但当时我写作更多是为了生存。为你自己写。为我自己写。
But Shoemaker, Mike Shoemaker, the producer in the show, he gave great advice where he's like, look, what you should do is you should try to think of group scenes where you can score, but it's not like a Seth sketch. You know, it's a, it's five people and it will get on the show and you will, you know, have a fifth of the laughs, but that'll be better than you, you know. I was, because early on, I would write things that were good enough to get to dress, but then I didn't have the, I don't know, the charisma or skill to carry it. So I was getting so many things cut at dress on the, you know, and again, it was an accomplishment to make it to dress.
但是舒梅克（Shoemaker），迈克·舒梅克（Mike Shoemaker），节目的制片人，他给出了很好的建议，他说，看，你应该做的是尝试构思一些群戏，你可以在其中得分，但那不像是一个塞斯（Seth）的小品。你知道，那是五个人的戏，它会出现在节目里，你会，你知道，获得五分之一的笑声，但这会比你，你知道。我当时，因为在早期，我会写一些好到足以进入彩排的东西，但我没有，我不知道，那种魅力或技巧来支撑它。所以我有很多东西在彩排时被砍掉了，你知道，而且再说一次，能进入彩排本身就是一种成就。
But then it just felt like a failure. That's, first of all, it's great that you had, Shue, and obviously I want to get into, you guys have managed to have an incredible sort of partnership, if you will, going forward, and that he gave you that advice at that time, and I want to get into that, but first I want to know,
但后来这感觉就像是一种失败。首先，很高兴你有舒（Shue），显然我想深入了解，你们在未来成功建立了一种令人难以置信的合作关系，如果可以这么说的话，而且他在那个时候给了你那个建议，我想深入了解这一点，但首先我想知道，
what's your favorite sketch that got cut at dress that never made it to air that you, to this day, you're like, this would have killed. Do you have one? I don't know. I mean, I remember, because we did this thing, we started doing this thing at our show called Second Chance Theater, where we would do sketches that had gotten cut at S&L,
你最喜欢哪个在彩排时被砍掉、从未播出的短剧，以至于直到今天你还觉得：这绝对会火。你有这样的短剧吗？我不知道。我是说，我记得，因为我们做了这件事，我们在我们的节目中开始做一件事叫“第二次机会剧场”（Second Chance Theater），我们会表演那些在SNL被砍掉的小品，
and then we would mount them on late night. But they were usually like crazy forte sketches, steak sketches, Will Ferrell. We did the Gabe Kaplan Will Ferrell sketch, which I'm sure you at some point Will had seen that dress up. And I remember one time she was like, we should do one of yours. And the only thing I liked about it was it was the beginning of a holiday ad,
然后我们会把它们搬到《深夜秀》（Late Night）上。但它们通常是像疯狂的福特（Forte）小品、牛排小品、威尔·法瑞尔的小品。我们做了盖布·卡普兰（Gabe Kaplan）威尔·法瑞尔的小品，我相信你在某个时候威尔在彩排时看过那个。我记得有一次她说，我们应该做你的一个。我唯一喜欢它的一点是，它是一个节日广告的开头，
which it was like, what do you get for a man who has everything, a second penis? And then it was just... And it was always... I took it, like basically submitted it all three December. shows for like my first five years on the show and never once went because it just ultimately and remember shoemaker's like we should do it and then I got a copy of it and Schemaker read it he's like I actually don't think we should do it so wait wait what what was the thing that always made it a non-candidate
内容是，给一个拥有一切的男人买什么？第二个阴茎？然后它就只是……而且它总是……我把它，基本上在前五年里，每个十二月的节目都提交了，但从来没上过，因为它最终，而且记得舒梅克说我们应该做它，然后我拿到了副本，舒梅克读了它，他说，我其实觉得我们不应该做它。等等，等等，那个总是让它成为非候选作品的原因是什么？
I just think it immediately became no it wasn't too graphic it was too much a sketch about a sketch where it was about how it was just the actual apparatus that the site was psychic was clumsy it was it was about how it was it like it was a clumsy strap Which is amazing. And they were, I remember Parnell was the host of it and there were three testimonials and at the end he goes, so it seems like, he goes, so
我只是觉得它立刻就变成了，不，它不是太露骨，它是太像一个关于小品的短剧了，它关于它只是实际的装置，那个通灵者，它是笨拙的。它是关于它如何，它是一个笨拙的带子。这太棒了。而且他们是，我记得帕内尔（Parnell）是那个小品的主持人，有三个证词，最后他说，所以看起来，他说，所以
one four, one against and one in the middle. They couldn't even get three strong testimonials. Can we just sideline and say how great Chris Parnell is? He's so great. He is world class. That dude fuck me, man. Well, there was, again, when I
一票赞成，一票反对，一票中立。他们甚至凑不出三个强有力的证词。我们能先暂停一下，说说克里斯·帕内尔有多棒吗？他太棒了。他是世界级的。那家伙，该死，伙计。嗯，有，再次强调，当我
I was so lucky to be a writer at a time on that show where just the toolbox was nuts. And I think certainly people who wrote for Phil Hartman had that same thing, but Chris Parnell was just a metronomic delivery system for information that he would do in a way that it felt like as though there was no, it was so dry that it became hilarious, but there was no effort, or it certainly,
我非常幸运能在那个节目的那个时期担任编剧，当时的工具箱简直太疯狂了。而且我认为，当然，为菲尔·哈特曼（Phil Hartman）写过剧本的人也有同样的感受，但克里斯·帕内尔简直就是一个节拍器般的台词交付系统，他会以一种感觉好像没有，它太干了以至于变得滑稽，但没有努力，或者至少，
no observable effort that he was like reaching for the laugh. He would just kind of get it. He says, oh, I always remember, every time I think of Parnell now, I think of that scene. There's a scene in 30 Rock where he plays that doctor, Spacham, and we're doing this scene, and he goes, and he's got to give somebody a shot,
没有明显的努力去博取笑声。他只是会得到它。他说，哦，我总是记得，每次我现在想到帕内尔，我就会想到那个场景。在《我为喜剧狂》（30 Rock）里有一个场景，他扮演那个医生，斯帕切姆（Spaceman），我们在拍这个场景，他说，他得给某人打针，
and he goes, okay, he takes the needle out, and he goes, okay, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, he's revolted at the idea of giving somebody a shot, and nobody else could do it the way he did it. It was just amazing. So that's, man, so then you, so Shoemaker's like, all right, you got to start writing, you got to start doing this stuff.
他说，好吧，他拿出针头，他说，好吧，呃，呃，呃，呃，呃，他对给某人打针的想法感到反感，没有人能像他那样做。这真是太神奇了。所以这就是，伙计，所以然后你，所以舒梅克说，好吧，你得开始写作，你得开始做这些事。
And then, and then you start writing more, and then update happens. There's a, there's a kind of a, a, there's an empty chair, Tina leaves. Yes. Yes. And to do 30 Rock. And the big thing is, who's going to take over the seat? Yes.
然后，然后你开始写更多，然后《周末更新》（Update）发生了。有一个，有一个空椅子，蒂娜离开了。是的。是的。去拍《我为喜剧狂》。而最大的事情是，谁来接管那个位置？是的。
Well, it was the second time it happened, right? because first Jimmy had left. Oh, yes. And, you know, in my head, I always, if I, if there was anybody at SNL whose path I thought I could maybe try to follow, it was Tina's, right? I always saw, I was like, oh, that's somebody who is a really good writer and also a good performer. But, you know what I mean? Like, she built her way to perform her on the, like, strength of her writing. And so, whereas, you know, again, when, you know, when you're next to Will Ferrell or, you know, Amy, and there's just like this charisma coming out of their performance.
嗯，这是第二次发生这种情况，对吧？因为首先吉米（Jimmy）离开了。哦，是的。而且，你知道，在我的脑海里，我总是，如果SNL里有谁的路径是我觉得我可以尝试跟随的，那就是蒂娜的，对吧？我总是看到，我觉得，哦，那是一个既是很好的编剧又是很好的表演者的人。但是，你知道我的意思吗？就像，她是靠着写作的实力一步步成为表演者的。所以，而，你知道，再次强调，当你，你知道，当你站在威尔·法瑞尔或，你知道，艾米（Amy）旁边，他们的表演中散发出一种魅力，
pores that is not available to you. You're like, all right, we're going to write our way into this. With that said, when Lauren decided to go with Amy and Tina, it wasn't like I thought he had made a bad choice. My best chance was that Amy didn't want to do it. I wasn't like, what are they thinking?
那是你所不具备的。你会觉得，好吧，我们要靠写作来进入这个领域。话虽如此，当洛恩决定选择艾米和蒂娜时，并不是我觉得他做出了错误的选择。我最好的机会是艾米不想做。我并不是在想，他们在想什么？
But then, yeah, when it was you know, when it was Amy in an open chair and my recollection of it was it was the end of that year And so I had done one year where Lorna promoted me to writing supervisor. So he had taken me as a cast member.
但后来，是的，当它是，你知道，当它是艾米坐在空椅子上时，我的记忆是那是那一年的年底。所以我做了一年，洛恩把我提升为写作主管。所以他把我当作演员。
And I think at this point he was admitting his mistake. He's like, I'd love you to, you know, basically, because Tina was gone a lot that year. Amsterdam, notwithstanding, I think them. You know, I'd like, I think, you know, in Amsterdam they like clowns. You know what, though, you were so great on update. I remember when Wigg and Armisen played those two characters where they, They're singers and they make albums, but of course they're improvising.
而且我认为在这一点上他承认了他的错误。他说，我很乐意你，你知道，基本上，因为蒂娜那一年经常不在。阿姆斯特丹，尽管如此，我想他们。你知道，我想，你知道，在阿姆斯特丹他们喜欢小丑。你知道吗，不过，你在《周末更新》上太棒了。我记得当威格（Wigg）和阿米森（Armisen）扮演那两个角色时，他们是歌手，他们制作专辑，但当然他们是在即兴创作。
Yeah, Garth and Cat. And they're singing, making it up in the moment, clearly. And you got as big of laughs as they did asking the dumbest, obvious questions. And it's hard to do that. And you just so excelled at that. I thought it was hilarious. Thank you.
是的，加斯（Garth）和凯特（Kat）。他们在唱歌，即兴创作，很明显。而你问那些愚蠢的、显而易见的问题时，得到的笑声和他们一样多。这很难做到。而你在这方面表现得非常出色。我觉得这太搞笑了。谢谢。
It is, to this day, they always would, they would ask to sing another song and they would say, please, Mr. Miners. They kept calling me Mr. Miners. And my wife will still say will refer to me as Mr. Miners when she wants me to do something. Knowing how well you guys all knew each other
直到今天，他们总是会，他们会要求唱另一首歌，他们会说，请，迈纳先生（Mr. Miners）。他们一直叫我迈纳先生。而我妻子现在还会称呼我为迈纳先生，当她想让我做某事的时候。知道你们所有人彼此有多了解，
and knowing how legitimately you were authentically delighted by so many of those players, watching other people come up. You and Amy doing update was phenomenal in and of itself, but watching how delighted you would be when, like, Fred would come out or Whig, and watching you be legit, like, you know what people would say? Like, oh, are they faking, laughing?
而且知道你对那些演员中的许多人是多么真诚地感到高兴，看着其他人崛起。你和艾米做《周末更新》本身就非常出色，但看着当弗雷德出来或者威格出来时，你会感到多么高兴，看着你真诚地，就像，你知道人们会说什么吗？就像，哦，他们是在假笑吗？
Like, no, no, no. Seth can't control himself because Fred is killing him right now. Right? And they're killing each other. And just, well, Fred and Whig and Bobby Moynihan. Yeah. They also just never, by the way, never tanked dress. They just always saved like three moves for air, which is,
就像，不，不，不。塞斯无法控制自己，因为弗雷德现在让他笑得不行。对吧？他们让彼此笑得不行。而且只是，嗯，弗雷德和威格和鲍比·莫伊尼汉（Bobby Moynihan）。是的。顺便说一句，他们也从来没有在彩排时搞砸过。他们总是为直播保留了三招，也就是，
I would never have the confidence to not give. like press so hard at drag it. Whereas they're like, I've got it. Like, I'm not going to do it all now. It was interesting, though, because when Amy left, you know, and I was doing it alone, my initial instinct, which is a bad one, because all update guests are doing a bad job executing what you, the anchor, tell the audience they're going to do.
我永远没有信心不在彩排时全力以赴。而他们就像，我有把握。就像，我不会现在就把一切都做出来。不过这很有趣，因为当艾米离开时，你知道，我独自做这件事，我的最初直觉，这是一个糟糕的直觉，因为所有的《周末更新》嘉宾都在做着糟糕的工作，执行着你，作为主播，告诉观众他们要做的事情。
For example, like, Stefan, the city correspondent, it was a terrible city correspondent. Right. And so my first instinct as an actor was to be frustrated and mad. Right. And again, not to continue to give him the credit he deserves, but Shoemaker was like, I think the audience doesn't like that you don't like them. Right.
例如，像斯特凡（Stefan），城市通讯员，他是一个糟糕的城市通讯员。对吧。所以作为演员，我的第一直觉是感到沮丧和生气。对吧。而且再次强调，不是为了继续给他应得的赞誉，但舒梅克说，我觉得观众不喜欢你不喜欢他们。对吧。
You know, he was basically like, I think just, I think you should try to play this as sort of patient and delighted. And it was such a good note because, of course, that, you know, to sort of confirm what you're saying, Will, like I was delighted. So, like, why hide it from the audience? Like, it just seemed like, you know, this. Because, again, I think maybe just from, like, I don't know what it was, like, what comedy you watch growing up,
你知道，他基本上是说，我觉得你应该尝试表现得有点耐心和高兴。这是一个非常好的建议，因为，当然，那，你知道，为了证实你所说的，威尔，就像我很高兴。所以，为什么要对观众隐藏它呢？就像，这看起来就像，你知道，这个。因为，再次强调，我想也许只是因为，就像，我不知道是什么，就像，你成长过程中看什么喜剧，
but, like, there's that straight man thing of, like, now you hold on here. You were supposed to be talking about this city, you know? And that's just, like, not joyful to do or watch. Right, right, right. We'll be right back. And back to the show. When Amy left and ends, because she chose our son over you,
但是，就像，有那种直男角色说，现在你等等。你本应该谈论这个城市的，你知道吗？而那只是，就像，做起来或看起来都不快乐。对吧，对吧，对吧。我们马上回来。回到节目。当艾米离开时，因为她选择了我们的儿子而不是你，
when she when Artie was born and you know what he's a fine young man and I'm finally willing to concede the right choice it's almost 18 years
当阿奇（Archie）出生时，你知道吗，他是个很好的年轻人，我终于愿意承认那是正确的选择，已经快18年了。
but uh and he's by the way he's still asleep he's in the other he's in his room right now he's still asleep yeah yeah but but when
但是，呃，而且顺便说一句，他还在睡觉，他在另一间，他在他的房间里，他还在睡觉。是的，是的，但是当
when you were now on the desk by yourself uh what was that like that first time do you remember that for a show being out there Well, I mean, because the first time was crazy,
当你现在独自坐在桌子后面时，呃，那是什么感觉，第一次，你还记得那次节目吗？嗯，我是说，因为第一次太疯狂了，
because it didn't, wasn't Archie born on a late Friday night? Well, of course. Yeah, of course. Yeah. No, you did that night by yourself. That, I think Saturday morning I woke up from a text from Amy being like so. She was in labor Saturday morning. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
因为那不是，阿奇不是在周五深夜出生的吗？嗯，当然。是的，当然。是的。不，你那天晚上是自己做的。我想周六早上我醒来时收到艾米的一条短信，说，所以。她周六早上在分娩。是的，是的，是的。
She was like, you're on your own. And I, but it was crazy. And it was also not the most confident. I've ever felt Lauren was. Oh, no. My ability is. Lauren had a lot of ideas of like, but what if you did it with this person just for tonight?
她说，你自己来吧。而且我，但这太疯狂了。而且那也不是我感觉最自信的一次。洛恩是。哦，不。我的能力是。洛恩有很多想法，比如，但如果你今晚和这个人一起做呢？
And I'm not, I will say, I'm not someone who advocates particularly well for myself. But that was, I remember just saying, I really, I think if you don't let me do it alone tonight, you're, it will just look like you don't think I can do it alone. Right. Uh-huh, right, right. And the eyes were on, you guys had had an amazing fall
而且我不是，我会说，我不是一个特别擅长为自己辩护的人。但我记得我只是说，我真的，我觉得如果你今晚不让我一个人做，你，这看起来就像你觉得我不能一个人做。对吧。呃，对，对，对。而且大家的目光都在，你们经历了一个很棒的秋天，
because it was the presidential race that year. Yes. You guys were every week crushing it. Well, I think maybe the, I mean, probably just based on, I remember, you know, her silhouette, it must have been her last update before Archie was the rap to Sarah Palin, right? So that's, so it is also. I mean, I do, I get that Lauren is like, so here's the thing. You going on alone without the woman who just hardcore rap to Sarah Palin,
因为那一年是总统竞选。是的。你们每周都在大获全胜。嗯，我想也许，我是说，可能只是基于，我记得，你知道，她的剪影，那一定是她在阿奇出生前最后一次《周末更新》，是关于莎拉·佩林（Sarah Palin）的，对吧？所以那是，所以它也是。我是说，我确实，我明白洛恩是，所以事情是这样的。你独自一人，没有那个刚刚对莎拉·佩林进行硬核说唱的女人，
like nine and a half months pregnant. Like, I think he was looking out for me, like, genuinely. Like, I don't think it was, he was probably like, let's just try to, like, have, give you a little help out there. But I think ultimately what we, and what ultimately my era of solo hosting update was, was, we'd just do a lot of features. You know what I mean?
就像怀孕九个半月。就像，我想他在照顾我，就像，真诚地。就像，我不认为那是，他可能就像，让我们试着，就像，给你一点帮助。但我认为最终我们，以及最终我独自主持《周末更新》的时代，是，我们只是做了很多专题。你知道我的意思吗？
Like, four jokes, Fred, four jokes. I will tell you something. I'll tell you something really cool, too, which, well, not, but I think it's cool, is we, of course, you know this very well, because you were texting in contact to Amy and Archie and I, and he was, watched that episode. live from the hospital.
就像，四个笑话，弗雷德，四个笑话。我会告诉你一些事。我也会告诉你一些很酷的事，虽然，不，但我认为这很酷，是我们，当然，你很清楚这一点，因为你当时在给艾米和阿奇发短信联系，而且他，看了那一集。从医院直播。
That was the first show Archie ever saw. It was incredible, man. It was, and it was very emotional for her and for you guys and for us and for me. And Maya sang that song. Yeah, Kenan and Maya, Titi and Mario, which was the first time with you, Jason.
那是阿奇看过的第一个节目。这太不可思议了，伙计。这，而且对她和你们以及我们和我来说都非常感人。而且玛雅（Maya）唱了那首歌。是的，基南（Kenan）和玛雅，蒂蒂（Titi）和马里奥（Mario），这是第一次和你，杰森（Jason）。
That was Titi and Mario was the soul singers. I'm gonna help him. You and Amy, you're on like a bearskin rug in front of... We're selling like a cake. On the show, on the show, not the time you guys went away to time. Oh, yes, yes, yes. Oh, you almost stepped in it. I did not lead you down a helpful path.
那是蒂蒂和马里奥是灵魂歌手。我会帮他。你和艾米，你们在像一张熊皮地毯上，在……前面。我们在卖像一个蛋糕。在节目上，在节目上，不是你们去度假的时候。哦，是的，是的，是的。哦，你差点踩进坑里。我没有引导你走上一条有帮助的道路。
That was, we sing those songs all the time, which is they were very short, very inappropriate soul songs. They were kind of like an Ashford and Simpson. And one of the songs, the entirety of one of the songs was, let me put it in a little bit, just the tip. Yeah, just the tip. They were very short songs. Oh, yeah, and then like a, like a, like a, like a,
那是，我们一直唱那些歌，也就是它们非常短，非常不合适的灵魂乐歌曲。它们有点像阿什福德和辛普森（Ashford and Simpson）。其中一首歌，整首歌的内容是，让我放进去一点点，只是一点点。是的，只是一点点。它们是非常短的歌。哦，是的，然后像一个，像一个，像一个，像一个，
smash zoom with the camera. Just a tab! Like right in on their face. Yeah, I remember that. Shaky, but that was... So T.T. Morrow, we're saying a song to Arta. Yeah. Sanged. Yeah, it was amazing.
摄像机的猛烈变焦。只是一个标签！就像直接对准他们的脸。是的，我记得那个。颤抖，但那是……所以蒂蒂·马里奥，我们在给阿奇唱一首歌。是的。唱了。是的，这太棒了。
That's so cool. But then you go, so that, now you're on your own and you end up, and however, you got it off the ground really well. You know, behind the scenes, Lauren, as you said, was maybe a little bit nervous and whatever. We'll see. But you end up.
这太酷了。但后来你走，所以那个，现在你独自一人，你最终，而且无论如何，你把它做得非常好。你知道，在幕后，洛恩，正如你所说，可能有点紧张之类的。我们走着瞧。但你最终。
Now, in a way, do you think that that prepared you for ultimately doing late night? Because you kind of grew in confidence, you handled it so well, the audience never sensed that. And I don't think that, and there's no, obviously you and Amy were great to get it. But you really owned that era of doing it yourself, and you took that into late night. Do you feel like that experience helped you? I think it helped people see me as somebody who could do late night, which is ultimately like the bigger problem as far as the jobs we want is you need the people who give those jobs out to see it.
现在，在某种程度上，你认为那为你最终做《深夜秀》做了准备吗？因为你的自信心增强了，你处理得非常好，观众从未察觉到。而且我不认为，而且没有，显然你和艾米很棒。但你确实掌控了那个独自主持的时代，并把它带到了《深夜秀》。你觉得那次经历有帮助吗？我觉得它帮助人们看到我是一个可以做《深夜秀》的人，这最终是，就我们想要的工作而言，更大的问题是你需要那些发放工作的人看到它。
And so that was great. But again, I had no eyes on it. And no one wants to go first. Yeah. And by the way, I owe a great credit to the fact that it worked for, that Jimmy made it work late night because I think, you know, ultimately the complete lack of originality in network thinking led them to like,
所以那很棒。但再次强调，我对此没有眼光。而且没有人想做第一个。是的。而且顺便说一句，我非常感谢吉米让《深夜秀》成功了，因为我认为，你知道，最终网络思维中完全缺乏原创性导致他们像，
what if that's the other update guy? Did Conan proceed Fallon? Yeah, yeah, yeah. But it was Conan and Jimmy and then... Right, and then it was Jay Conan and Jimmy, and then it was Jay and Jimmy. It was a fun time. But how many years have you done the late show?
如果那是另一个《周末更新》的人呢？柯南（Conan）在法伦（Fallon）之前吗？是的，是的。但那是柯南和吉米，然后……对，然后是杰（Jay）和吉米。那是杰和吉米。那是一段有趣的时光。但你做《深夜秀》多少年了？
Like 12. It started in 2014. Yeah, 2014. February will be 12 years. No, February will be 13. Yeah. It's nuts. But it was...
大概12年。它始于2014年。是的，2014年。二月将是12年。不，二月将是13年。是的。这太疯狂了。但它是……
I will say a lot of the update stuff actually, I think, worked against figuring out the show because of... You know, one thing was so much of... update was about me and the best cast, one of the best cast in the history of SNL. And then you're like, now it's you without any of that. And-
我会说很多《周末更新》的东西实际上，我认为，对弄清楚这个节目起了反作用，因为……你知道，有一件事是，很多……《周末更新》是关于我和最好的演员，SNL历史上最好的演员之一。然后你会觉得，现在是你，没有那些。而且-
But maybe without the cast, but, and we'd go back to Shoemaker, a guy who had worked closely with you in the writing, first of all, I'd encouraged you. Yes. And then you guys really partnered, and you guys went and did it together. You had a really great, solid... You guys knew each other.
但也许没有演员，但是，我们回到舒梅克，一个在写作上与你密切合作的人，首先，我鼓励过你。是的。然后你们真的合作了，你们一起去做了。你们有一个非常棒的、坚实的……你们彼此了解。
That's such a cheat, because often I think when you start late night, not that I know, you're really... really you're hoping it works out. You're hoping the dynamic works out. You guys had years of working together. We had a shorthand. We had an agreement about what I was good at
这真是一个作弊，因为通常我认为当你开始做《深夜秀》时，并不是我知道，你真的……你真的希望它成功。你希望这种动态能成功。你们有多年合作的经验。我们有速记。我们对我不擅长什么和我不擅长什么达成了一致。而且我们也曾在一起，当时我尝试了所有关于，比如，我要成为SNL的常规小品演员，但没有奏效的事情。我们看着它失败，没有结出任何果实。所以，但让我感到非常沮丧的事情，我带着爱说这一点，
and what I hadn't been good at. And we had also been there together while I had tried all the stuff that had not worked about like, I'm going to be a regular sketch cast player on SNL. And we'd kind of watch that fail to, you don't bear any fruit. And so, but the thing that frustrates me so much, and I say this would love,
我记得洛恩说你需要18个月才能弄清楚。而我有信心觉得，我会花18个月。然后节目进行到18个月时，我当时想，我要停止做站立独白，我要在桌子后面开始节目。我记得，我甚至没意识到已经18个月了，但那一刻我做了，我心想，哦，就是这个。
I remember Lauren said it'll take you 18 months to figure it out. And I had the confidence to be like, I'd take me 18 months. And then 18 months into the show is when I was like, I'm going to stop doing a standing monologue and I'm going to start the show at the desk. And I remember, I didn't even realize it had been 18 months, but the minute I did that, I'm like, oh, this is it.
然后我心想，哦，该死。就这样。然后所以，但在SNL，你是，你是在领导写作过程吗？你不是吗？你是首席编剧，无论是名义上还是实际上？我是首席编剧。我基本上是我在节目中任期结束时的首席编剧。
And then I'm like, oh, fuck. Just right. Then so, but on SNL, were you, how much of the, you were leading the writing process? Were you not? Were you headwriter either in name or in practicality? I was headwriter. I was headwriter for basically the end of my run on the show.
就像我是《周末更新》和首席编剧。而且我会说直到今天，就像可能这个头衔，如果为头衔感到自豪不是太愚蠢的话，我最自豪的是我曾是SNL的首席编剧。是的，你应该这样。但再次强调，就像，主要是你，你知道，最困难或最无用的时刻是我把洛恩的笔记带给编剧团队。
Like I was update and head writer. And I will say to this day, like probably the title, if it's not too silly to be proud of titles, the thing I'm proudest of is the fact that I was the headwriter in SNL. Yeah, as you should be. But again, like, it's you mostly, you know, the hardest or the most Utahile I was is bringing notes from Lauren to the writing staff.
就像，我工作，那个编剧团队没有我也会很好。他们从头到尾都是绝对的顶尖高手。那是一群不可思议的人。然后你基本上，显然默认地和名义上，成为了你自己节目的首席编剧。那么，比较这两个工作量、职位、责任水平。所以实际上是亚历克斯·贝斯（Alex Bays），他是《周末更新》的首席编剧，是我离开时挖走的唯一一个人。而且那个人，我一得到
Like, I worked, that writing staff would have been fine without me. They were just absolute top-to-bottom bangers. It was an incredible group of people. You then basically, obviously by default and title, become head writer on your own show. And how, compare those two workloads, positions, levels of responsibility. So it's actually Alex Bays, who was the head writer at Weekend Update, was the one person I poached when I left. And the one person, as soon as I got the
工作，洛恩说的第一件事就是，你不能要贝斯。连洛恩都知道他有多好。他是最伟大的在世笑话作家。他不可思议。所以他是我们的首席编剧。而这份工作，我仍然在我的节目中做大量的写作，但我只做重写。
job, the first thing Lauren said was, you can't have Bays. Even Lauren knew how good he was. He's the greatest living joke writer. He's incredible. And so he's our head writer. And the job, I still do a ton of writing on my show, but I only rewrite.
就像，我在SNL的大部分时间都是那样，就像，打开，你知道，就像写作中最糟糕的部分，空白页。我记得乔斯特（Jost）在他的办公室里，就像，直到今天，我会进去，因为那是我的旧办公室，他有所有演员的名字，
Like, so much of my time at S&L was that, like, open on, you know, like the worst part of writing, just blank page. I remember Jost in his office, like, had a, to this day, I'll go in, because it's my old office, and he has the names of all the cast,
就像打印出来的，就像，而且我有时会想，你只是想看名字并希望，就像，任何能让你开始的东西？对。就像，谁，谁做什么？对。
like just printed, just like, and I think of like, sometimes you just want to look at names and hope that, like, just anything to get you started? Right. Like, who, who does what? Right.
所以能过渡到我职业生涯中重写多于写作的部分真是太好了。明白了。我是说，我去了，我想我2017年回去主持过。我才离开三年，我就有了这个，你知道，宏伟计划。我心想，我要回去，
And so it is lovely to have transitioned to a part of my career where I'm rewriting more than writing. Gotcha. I mean, I went, I think I went back and hosted in 2017. I'd only been gone three years, and I had this, you know, grand plan. I'm like, I'm going to get back,
我要活动活动手指，写几个老派的小品。而我只是，这感觉就像有人试图，这，记得马克·斯皮茨（Mark Spitz）回来试图在奥运会上游泳吗？你看到了，就像，他的一张照片，你会觉得，他看起来仍然不错。然后他跳进泳池，你会觉得，不，不，不。
I'm going to crack my knuckles, write a couple of old, old school sketching. And I just, it felt like somebody trying to, it was, remember when Mark Spitz came back and tried to swim in the Olympics? And you saw, like, a picture of him, and you're like, he still looks good. And then he just got in the pool, and you're like, no, no, no.
就像，感觉就是那样。工作时间应该差不多，或者更好，或者更糟？不，不，不，这太不可思议了。我现在的时间和SNL相比。我不知道怎么。是更好还是更糟？所以，现在是最好的。我不知道如果我有SNL的工作时间，我怎么能有一个家庭，
Like, that's how it felt. The hours have got to be similar or better or worse? No, no, no, this is unbelievable. My hour is now compared to the essay. I don't know how. Is better or worse? So, right now it's the best. I don't know how I could have had a family with SNL hours
像我现在这样。我是说，我们在下午4点录制我们的节目，而且我们不做事后总结。再次强调，舒梅克，他的原则是，看，我们，如果明天有什么让你生气的事，我们开个会。但如果你回家，我敢打赌你明天来的时候会更关心今晚的节目。
in the way that I do now. I mean, we tape our show at 4 in the afternoon, and we don't do a post-mortem. Again, Shoemaker, his thing was like, look, we, if there's something you're mad about tomorrow, let's have a meeting. But if you go home, I bet you'll come in tomorrow and be more concerned about tonight's show.
对。你会意识到你生气的事情，每个人都注意到它出错了，没有人会想让它再出错，而且最终，让我们说，我们自己，你知道，90分钟。这太有趣了。因为再次强调，你只是一个接一个地把它们做出来。
Right. You'll realize that the thing you're mad about, everybody noticed that it went wrong, and nobody will want it to go wrong again, and ultimately, let's say, ourselves, you know, 90 minutes. It's so interesting. Because again, you're just churning them out one after the other.
而且不是以一种坏的方式。我不是那个意思，不是负面的意思，但它确实迫使你展望未来，并尝试慢慢地提出。但它是每天的，对吧？只是代替了每周。尽管SNL的日常工作量，从我有限的视角来看，确实看起来相当严格，我想在你的，你目前的节目中，它要复杂得多。
And not in a bad way. I don't mean that in a negative way, but it does really force you to look to the future and just try to slowly bring up. But it is daily, right? Except instead of weekly. Even though the daily workload on SNL, from my limited view of it, it does seem pretty rigorous, I would imagine on your, your show currently, it is much more involved.
它是，我是说，再次强调，我一大早就到了，我整天都在工作。就像，没有，没有停机时间。但它并不无聊，因为它是所有，你知道，你们都在朝着这个非常令人兴奋的发布努力。而且，你知道，那种走进一个有180人观看的演播室的肾上腺素激增。这太酷了。
It's, I mean, again, I get there first thing in the morning, and I'm working the whole day. Like, there's no, there's no downtime. But it's not boring because it's all, you know, you're all churning towards this really exciting release. And, you know, the, the adrenaline rush of walking out into a studio where, you know, 180 people are there to watch it. That's so cool.
你是否觉得你必须有意识地，因为，因为它每天都有，而且你确实处理，你知道，时事，你是否觉得需要，就像，该死，我今天早上得翻遍每一份报纸。我需要了解每一个，不？我有时觉得我从第一稿中获取新闻。是的，对。而且我心想，那也很好。我是说，就像，你知道，再次强调，就像，并不是我不看社交媒体，
Do you feel like you have to consciously because of, because it is daily and you do deal with, you know, topical things, do you feel the need to, like, fuck, I got to plow through every newspaper this morning. I need to be up on every, no? I sometimes feel like I get my news from the first draft. Yeah, right. And I'm like, that's also fine. I mean, like, you know, again, like, it's not like I'm not looking at social media
并滚动浏览推特，看看，就像，世界上正在发生什么。所以我不是，就像，被抓个措手不及。但我没有，你知道，在周日，我，你知道，认为看，你知道，很多，你知道，周日新闻节目很重要。是的。但是，就像，我不是，我不觉得我是什么，你知道，贪得无厌的新闻迷，为了我的节目的目的，这很好。
and scrolling through Twitter and seeing, like, what's happening in the world. So I'm not, like, caught flat-footed. But I don't, you know, On Sunday, do I, you know, think it's important to watch, you know, a lot of the, you know, Sunday news shows. Yeah. But, like, I'm not, I don't feel like I'm some, you know, insatiable news junkie for the purposes of my show, which is nice.
你总是可以打电话给贝特曼（Bateman）。你总是可以打电话给贝特曼。是的。我会让你加入。是的。你有没有厌倦过它？我是说，你有没有，就像，你需要休息？你知道，我们正在，你知道，我们在休假期间交谈。
You can always just call Bateman. You could just call Bateman. Yeah. I'll plug you in. Yeah. Do you ever get tired of it, though? I mean, do you ever get, like, you need a break? You know, we're on, you know, we're talking during a hiatus.
我想也许当有播出的时候。我们会回来的。我迫不及待地想回来。就像，真诚地，我爱和我一起工作的人。我也，你知道，这是一个非常，希望这是一个值得一看的宣泄节目，而且做起来非常宣泄。所以我的心理健康更加锁定，
I think maybe when there's air. We'll be back on. I can't wait to be back on. Like, genuinely, I love the people I work with. I also, you know, it's a very, hopefully it's a cathartic show to watch, and it's very cathartic to do. So my mental health is a lot more locked in
当我把这个节目作为一种方式，就像，你知道，焦虑倾倒。你期待做什么，抱歉，威利（Willie），当你们在夏天停工时，你每年最期待和家人做的事情是什么？是，是像，是旅行吗？是无所事事吗？是只是玩过家家吗？
when I have this show as a way to sort of like, you know, anxiety dumb. What do you look forward to doing, sorry, Willie, on that when you guys are powered down during the summer, what is the thing you look most forward to doing with the family each year? Is it just, is it like, is it travel? Is it doing nothing? Is it just playing house?
你知道，我们有，我们有海滩孩子。我有一个有船的岳父。强烈推荐有一个有船的岳父。只是一艘小摩托艇。当然。只是，你知道，但这和你的孩子一起做是一件好事。我明白了。但总的来说，他们也是，你知道，他们10岁，8岁，
You know, we got, we got beach kids. I got a father-in-law with a boat. Highly recommend having a father-in-law with a boat. Just a little motorboat. Sure. Just, you know, but that's a good thing to do with your kids. I got it. But in general, they're also, you know, they're 10, 8,
而且我女儿快五岁了。现在是很好的陪伴。是的。第一次我真的觉得，你知道吗？你们都没那么无聊了。是的。而且在这个年龄段更自给自足，对吧？
and my daughter's almost five. Just good company right now. Yeah. For the first time where I'm really like, you know what? You're all a lot less boring. Yeah. And there's much more self-sufficient at that age, right?
是的。嗯，那是诅咒，对吧？就像，他们不无聊的那一刻，他们就像，嘿，我在见其他人。我心想，是的，是的。我知道你看很多，历史上你看过很多电影，你看过很多节目。
Yeah. Well, that's the curse, right? Like, the minute they're not boring, they're like, hey, I'm meeting other people. I'm like, yeah, yeah. I know you watch a lot, historically you've watched a lot of films, you watch a lot of shows.
就像你喜欢吸收各种艺术，如果可以这么说的话。什么是，什么是，而且你看很多体育运动，你说你不玩，但你确实，你看大量的体育运动。什么是，什么是你做的事情？你在看《甲板下》（Below Deck）像J.B.和我一样吗？你是那样的吗？《寡妇湾》（Widows Bay）。
is like you enjoy absorbing all sorts of art, if you will. What are the thing, what's the thing that, and you watch a lot of sports, you say you don't play, but you do, you watch a ton of sports. What's the thing, what is the thing that you do? Are you watching below deck like J.B. and me? Are you anything like that? Widows Bay.
那是最后一个我真正喜欢的节目。马修·瑞斯（Matthew Rhys）很棒。是的。那家伙没有。真的很好。一个非常好的人。这是我感觉我最后一件，你有没有看过纪录片，像真实犯罪纪录片？
That was my last show that I really love. Matthew Reese is great. Yeah. That dude doesn't. Really good. A very good dude. That's the last thing I feel like I, Do you ever watch documentaries, like true crime documentaries?
没有太多的连贯性。我喜欢它们。然后什么是首选运动？是橄榄球吗？是钢人队（Steelers）的橄榄球吗？这取决于，我会说，就像，如果你的棒球队很好，夏天关心棒球会很有趣。但我会说像……
Not with much consistency. I love them. And then what is the go-to sport? It's football? It's Steelers' football? It depends on, I will say, like, if you have, if your baseball team is any good, it's very fun in the summer to care about baseball. But I would say like...
而你的球队是什么？红袜队（Sox）？红袜队，然后还有，我爸爸来自匹兹堡，所以海盗队（Pirates）程度较小。然后，但钢人队100%。而且那个，我确实感觉。就像我正在为那个情感过山车做准备。不是以一种我很兴奋的方式。有人，就像，你们是你们成长地之外的运动队的粉丝吗？
And what is your team? Sox? The Red Sox, and then also, my dad's from Pittsburgh, so the Pirates to a smaller degree. And then, but the Steelers 100%. And that, I do feel. like I'm gearing up for that emotional rollercoaster. Not in a way to where I'm excited. Are anybody, like, are you guys fans of sports teams outside of where you grew up?
是的。不。我是说，我是个自由派。你不是在波士顿长大的，塞斯，对吧？嗯，新罕布什尔州是，你知道，我们有波士顿体育频道。该死的就在旁边，伙计。就像，就在旁边。虽然，我讲一个故事，就像，我曾经在一个慈善活动上，一个沃尔伯格（Wahlberg），我不会
Yeah. No. I mean, I'm a liberal. You didn't grow up in Boston, Seth, right? Well, New Hampshire is, you know, we got the Boston sports channels. Fucking right next to it, dude. It's like, right next to it. Although, I tell a story, like, I was at a charity event once, and a Wahlberg, I won't
说哪一个。他就像，你是波士顿人吗？我说我来自新罕布什尔州。他说，所以不是。我心想，这就是那种省级的粗鲁，来自一个像收到《波士顿环球报》（Boston Globe）的人。我心想，我在《波士顿环球报》送达的范围内。送货上门，是的。嗯，你能想象被称为新英格兰红袜队吗？
say which one. He was like, are you from Boston? And I said, I'm from New Hampshire. And he said, so no. I was like, that is the perfect sort of provincial rudeness of someone who like gets the Boston Globe. I'm like, I'm within the window of the Boston Globe getting delivered. Home delivery, yeah. Well, could you imagine ever being called the New England Red Sox?
我是说，那会给你一个借口，对吧？但他们没有。是的，新英格兰爱国者队（Patriots）做了。但这太有趣了，因为，就像，我，再次强调，你知道，我在芝加哥起步。芝加哥完全拥有我。我爸爸来自匹兹堡。匹兹堡完全拥有我。波士顿，只是在中间。
I mean, that would give you an excuse then, right? But they don't. Yeah, the New England Patriots do it. But it is, it's so funny because, like, I, again, you know, I got my start in Chicago. Chicago totally owns me. My dad's from Pittsburgh. Pittsburgh totally owns me. Boston, just kind of in the middle.
从来不是小熊队（Cubs）。你知道我的意思吗？从来不是小熊队？他们相当不可知论，从来不是小熊队。从来不是白袜队（White Sox）？不。而且从来不是熊队（Bears）。对。
Never the Cubs. You know what I mean? Never the Cubs? They're pretty agnostic, never the Cubs. Never the White Sox? No. And never the Bears. Right.
不。好吧。我只是不在乎。我有一个。我有一个真爱，我不需要更多。明白了。当然。你认为，每个人都一直问这个，你认为……中东会发生什么？
No. Okay. I just didn't care. I had a. I had a true love, and I didn't need more. Got it. Sure. What do you think, everybody asks this all the time, what do you think... Is going to happen in the Middle East?
嗯，别让我开始。直通车是开着的，好吗？顺便说一句，以防你不知道，它正在营业。它是敞开的。而且，顺便说一句，无论我们录制这个的时间距离它出来的时间有多远，都没关系。它会保持开放。它仍然是开放的。它从来没有关闭过。
Well, don't get me started. The straight-to-ho-ho-hoose is open, okay? By the way, in case you didn't know, it's open for business. It's wide-open. And, by the way, it doesn't matter how far we're recording this based on when it comes out. It's going to stay open. It's still open. It's never been closed.
最后一件事。未来五年，如果你必须看，因为我们正在谈论，就像，你在我们的咖啡聊天中想要做什么，正如J.B.所说，你看到它走向哪里？你想做什么？看，我是说，我不知道。我很乐意说五年后，我还在做《深夜秀》。我一点也不厌倦它。我真的，真的非常喜欢它。但是，你知道，我确实认为比我在SNL学到的东西帮助我弄清楚《深夜秀》更多。就像，我想，就像，我在《深夜秀》所做的事情将是帮助我弄清楚很多事情的事情。
Last thing. next five years through, if you had to look, because we were talking about, like, what do you want to do in the preamble in our coffee chat, as J.B. calls it, what do you see it going? What do you want to do? Look, I mean, I don't know. I would love to say in five years from now, I'm still doing late night. I have no, I'm not tired of it at all. I really, really enjoy it. But, you know, I do think more than maybe even the things I learned at S&L help me figure out late night. Like, I think, like, what I've done at late night will be stuff that will help me figure out a great many things.
而且最终，我离开SNL时的恐惧是，就像，哦，我太担心我的下一份工作会很无聊了。而这个并不无聊。所以我认为关键只是找到一些你不觉得无聊的事情。嗯，我不认为你必须担心。你是一个伟大的喜剧头脑。你是一个伟大的头脑。人们喜欢看你，包括我。
And ultimately, the fear I had leaving SNL was like, oh, I'm so worried my next job is going to be boring. And this one isn't. So I think the key is just to find something where you're just not bored. Well, I don't think you have to worry. You're a great comedy mind. You're a great mind. People love watching you, including me.
你超级，超级有趣。你是一个很棒的人才。是的，你会找到的。这真是太多的时间了。而且你没有B计划。而且你没有B计划。没有B计划。甚至没有。
You're super, super funny. You're a wonderful talent set. Yeah, you're going to find. This was so much time. And you've got no plan B. And you've got no plan B. No plan B. Not even.
这么多年过去了，没有B计划。所以你会没事的。是的。是的。嘿，杰森，我知道你不能，但我能听到你。谢谢。哦，哇。谢谢。
All these years later, not a plan B. So you're going to be just fine. Yeah. Yeah. And hey, Jason, I know you couldn't, but I can hear you. Thank you. Oh, wow. Thank you.
而且你看到了我。我能听到你。是的，我也能看到你。我们爱你，塞斯·迈耶斯（Seth Myers）。我爱你，塞斯。谢谢你来，伙计。谢谢你做这件事。好吧，伙计们。
And you see me. I can hear you. Yeah, I can see you too. We love you, Seth, Myers. I love you, Seth. Thank you for coming, dude. Thank you for doing this. All right, guys.
我很快会见到你们。谢谢，塞斯。好吧，再见，塞斯。谢谢。伟大的塞斯·迈耶斯。他太棒了。你知道你可以看出他是一个伟大的编剧和一个伟大的，
I'll see you soon. Thanks, Seth. All right, bye, Seth. Thank you. The great Seth Myers. He's so great. You know what you can tell he's a great writer and a great,
我很快就会见到你。谢谢，塞斯。好的，再见，塞斯。谢谢你。伟大的塞斯·梅耶斯。他太棒了。你知道你可以看出他是一位伟大的作家，也是一位伟大的，
person of comedy just because of his natural wit like he's so funny naturally just speaking so witty well I love he's so conversational in his show on his show and as you said and so witty
他是个喜剧天才，仅仅是因为他天生的机智，他说话自然而然就那么风趣，那么机智。我喜欢他在节目中那种谈话风格，正如你所说，非常机智。
yeah so fast like crazy fast fast fast fasts yeah I mean we've all done his show right we've all been on his show and he's I don't know how you do that every single day where you're just on on on on and he's so natural on it
是啊，反应太快了，快得离谱，快得惊人。我们都上过他的节目，对吧？我们都去过，我不知道他是怎么做到每天都保持那种状态的，一直处于兴奋点上，而且表现得那么自然。
Anyway, he's one of the best. Yeah, it's super smooth, always so kind and gregarious, and he's just a... So smart. So smart. Yeah. He is a perfect host, for sure. It really is. God.
总之，他是最棒的之一。没错，他非常圆滑，总是那么友善、热情，而且他就是……太聪明了。太聪明了。是的，他绝对是一个完美的主持人。确实如此。天哪。
And I feel, is that the first time he's been on the show? Yeah, isn't that crazy? What is the deal? I don't know, right? I don't know. And then I ran into him last year. We've been trying to put this together for almost a year, just with dates and stuff. And, because I was like, how did we not...
我觉得，这是他第一次上这个节目吗？是啊，这不是很疯狂吗？到底是怎么回事？我不知道，对吧？我不知道。然后我去年碰到了他。我们为了凑时间，几乎花了一年时间才把这件事定下来。因为我当时就在想，我们怎么会没……
Yeah, I mean, he was, he's definitely, you know, he's definitely, why do I see, why do I see you coming from around the corner? Every time, like he chokes the puppy. I think he literally grabs the microphone and he gets an idea. Sean, what is he? Well, I just want to say he wasn't, he wasn't on today by accident. He was on today, no, he wasn't on today. Still rolling. Jesus age.
是啊，我的意思是，他绝对是，你知道，他绝对是，为什么我看到你从拐角处走过来？每次都像他掐住小狗一样。我想他真的是抓起麦克风，然后就有了个主意。肖恩，他是什么？好吧，我只是想说他今天不是偶然来的。他今天来，不，他今天没来。还在录制中。天哪。
He was on today because he was purposefully on today. He wasn't on by accident? I mean, less committal. Will you got anything? No, I don't know. You know, I'm sorry, Sean, but I don't. Bye. Bye.
他今天来是因为他特意安排在今天。他不是偶然来的？我的意思是，没那么确定。威尔，你有什么要说的吗？不，我不知道。你知道，抱歉，肖恩，但我没有。再见。再见。
Bye. There we go. Bye. Bye. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly. handcrafted by Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry. Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。就这样。再见。再见。《Smartless》是百分之百有机且手工制作的。《Smartless》是百分之百有机且由罗伯·阿姆贾夫、本内特·巴比科和迈克尔·格兰特·特里手工制作的。聪明。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。